Arkansas Senator Tom cotton you went out
early on this and I remember watching
and I'm looking and I'm listening
because I've always viewed you is very
credible I wasn't sure of it all did my
own investigative work I didn't have a
definitive answer I still don't but I'm
listening to what you're saying and what
Brett's saying what do you think that
where do you think this story leads well
Sean since January I've said it seems to
be highly coincidental that this very
contagious virus originated just a few
hundred yards or maybe a couple miles
from laboratories where the Chinese
Communist Party researches coronaviruses
Brett bears reporting tonight if it
bears out shows that the Chinese
Communist Party is responsible for every
single death every job lost every
retirement nest egg lost from this
coronavirus ng Jinping and his Chinese
communist apparatchiks must be made to
pay the price if that turns out to be
true well they certainly hold a lot of
America's dead is that an area where we
could perhaps get compensation we can
examine that area Sean I think we need
to make the American courts open for
lawsuits against Chinese communist
leaders I have legislation that would
modify the foreign Sovereign Immunities
Act to do just that I think we're going
to begin to see a massive shift of
manufacturing capacity out of China and
back to the United States or at least a
friendly allied countries which would be
devastating to the Chinese economy but
just imagine not just in America but all
around the world the demands for
accountability and consequences on the
Chinese Communist Party and Chairman gee
if it turns out that Chinese negligence
and then Chinese corruption and
treachery was responsible for unleashing
this pandemic on the world if Brett's
report bears out as you said I have no
reason to doubt it will it certainly
speaks volumes they weren't allowing
travel from Wuhan to any other area
China but they were perfectly willing to
let people in Wuhan travel to the rest
of the world that needs to be addressed
and answered senator cotton thank you